inzwischen sind es schon 51 je oller
verdachtsfälle im kongo das
erschreckende zum ersten mal gab es
einen ebola verdachtsfall in einer
millionenstadt werden ja darüber
berichtet das ist eine große gefahr
aber die weltgesundheitsorganisation
reagiert dieses mal deutlich schneller
als bei der letzten epidemie bei der
zwischen 2014 und 2016 mehr als 11.000
menschen in westafrika starben wird es
dieses mal so weit kommen
die aktuelle entwicklung bei klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
es ist bereits der neunte ausbruch im
kongo von ebola in den letzten 40 jahren
und bisher hält er sich noch in grenzen
das sind gott sei dank noch sehr
übersichtliche zahlen die da aus dem
kongo gemeldet werden bisher 51
verdachtsfälle und 27 tote wobei sich
die verdachtsfälle während der letzten
epidemie fast immer alle erhärtet hatten
aber dieses mal hat die
weltgesundheitsorganisation wer wirklich
sehr schnell reagiert der
generalsekretär der whu petrus g3 jesus
war schon vor ort und konnte jetzt auf
der jahrestagung der whu aus erster hand
berichten er ist sehr besorgt über den
patienten in der millionenstadt
andererseits sieht er die whu deutlich
besser vorbereitet als noch 2014 am
flughafen der millionenstadt werden alle
ankommenden passagiere auf fieber
untersucht und im gegensatz zum ausbruch
2014 gibt es jetzt endlich einen
impfstoff er ist zwar noch nicht
zugelassen wird aber jetzt bereits im
kongo eingesetzt alle personen die mit
erkrankten zu tun haben dass in rund 600
werden jetzt kämpft damit wird das
risiko eines super verarbeiters deutlich
gesenkt das könnte zum beispiel eine
pflegerin oder ein pfleger sein der dann
zahlreiche gesunde anstecken würde
allerdings ist das alles keine garantie
dass der ausbruch wirklich kontrolliert
werden kann bei der letzten wm in
westafrika was unter anderem eine
heilerin die zur super verbreitet wurde
und letztlich können ja auch nicht alle
reisenden in und aus der stadt
kontrolliert werden so hat die aktuelle
epidemie zwei seiten zum einen war die
weltgesundheitsorganisation noch nie so
gut vorbereitet zum anderen gab es aber
noch nie einen fall so früh in einer
millionenstadt ist bleibt also leider
sehr spannend im kongo wenn ihr nichts
zu holen und zu allen anderen dem
verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei
whatsapp und den anderen messengern nur
dann verpasst ihr kein video ihr wisst
ja die abo box bei youtube die ist ja
nicht so zuverlässig dann erfahrt ihr
von mir vor allen andern vom neuesten
video täglich und garantiert einfach
hier draufklicken und zur begrüßung habe
ich ein kleines juli und am besten auch
meinen schwesterkanal kriegs zum social
and media abonnieren da geht's auch hier
hin da ihr vater das neueste aus der
social media welt nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken ja
mit allen infos zur aktuellen ebola
epidemie ja ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran